- Okay, thank you all for joining us.
It's my delight today to
introduce John T. Sidel
who is the Sir Patrick Gillam Professor
of International and Comparative Politics
at the London school of
Economics and Political Science.
Professor Sidel holds a
BA and an MA from Yale
and received his PhD from Cornell.
I pulled up his dissertation from Cornell
just to look at the acknowledgements page,
and I won't go into all
the nitty-gritty details
but I was interested to
note that he's been involved
in the study of Philippines
and Southeast Asia
since at least 1985 when he
had an internship in Manila.
But as he says in the
acknowledgements page
of the dissertation, he was
only able to detach himself
from what he calls his
quote, adolescent adventures
in the realm of US
foreign policy, end quote,
and then become a serious
Southeast Asianist
after attending Yale, where he
then went on to become known
for his erudite critiques of the legacy
of US policy in the Philippines.
So I'd like to think
that it's Yale's Council
on Southeast Asian Studies
that had a formative role in his career.
As an undergraduate at Yale,
he studied with Hal Conklin and Jim Scott.
And then he went on to study
with Ben Anderson at Cornell.
And I like to mention these
Yale to Cornell stories
because there really are several.
Eric Tagliacozzo comes to mind.
Tom Pepinsky also comes to
mind, people going from Yale
and then taking up positions at Cornell
because they also remind
me of my own passage
from the other direction,
from Cornell to Yale.
And they really bring up and
solidify all the connections
and mutual inspiration
we have and that we get
from each other across
this Yale-Cornell network.
But I also hope that today's talk
can be part of an ongoing connection
between Yale Southeast
Asian Studies and the LSE
where John has been teaching since 2004.
And also, so as where
he taught before that
in other universities working
on Southeast Asia in the UK.
I really hope that we can forge
some more transnational connections
for the study of Southeast Asian studies.
John Sidel, as you know,
is the author of numerous
books and articles.
I've just going to mention some of them.
"Capital, Coercion, and Crime"
which emerged from that dissertation,
"Bossism in the Philippines,"
Stanford University Press 1999.
Coauthored with Eva-Lotta Hedman is
"Philippine Politics and Society
in the Twentieth Century:
Colonial Legacies,
Post-colonial Trajectories,"
Routledge, 2000.
"Riots, Pogroms, Jihad:
Religious Violence in Indonesia,"
Cornell Press, 2006.
"The Islamist Threat in
Southeast Asia: A Reassessment"
for the East-West Center in 2007
along with Jaime Faustino,
"Thinking and Working Politically
in Development: Coalitions
for Change in the Philippines"
published for the Asia Foundation in 2020.
And of course the book we'll
be learning about today,
"Republicanism, Communism, Islam:
Cosmopolitan Origins of
Revolution in Southeast Asia"
which is just out now from
Cornell University Press,
literally just off the press here in 2021.
I'll stop my comments
there just so we can really
spend all our time listening
to John, but please do join me
in welcoming John Sidel
for today's discussion
of his new book, John.
- Many thanks, Erik, for that
very generous introduction.
I'm not sure I deserve it at all,
but certainly Yale deserves my thanks
and the Council for
Southeast Asian Studies
and these Brown Bag Seminars
for first drawing me
into that sense of community, that kind
of cosmopolitan archipelagic
network as you put it,
some call it a mafia,
across Southeast Asian studies centers
and universities across the world.
So it's been a pleasure and a privilege.
And I hope that I will honor
some of the people here,
actually, I've seen are
attending in terms of their work
by talking about my book,
which I hope is in some ways
can be understood as a tribute
to a broader set of trends
in the historiography of Southeast Asia.
So what I'd like to do
today is give you a flavor
of the book and also give
you a sense of its structure
and the core argument, and
in doing so, I will now
throw up some PowerPoint
slides, in large measure photos
because sadly, the book
is not filled with photos
as it perhaps would be better
embellished with photos,
but at least this gives some of the flavor
and evokes some of the
kind of lived realities
that I'm trying to evoke in the book.
So there we see the title.
So in terms of the flavor for
the book, I should acknowledge
that the book has a kind
of a seemingly rambling
narrative style in the
beginning of the chapters
on the successive
revolutions that I treat.
And it begins in seemingly strange places.
So for example, the first two chapters
following the introduction, two chapters
on the Philippine Revolution
begin in the obscure
small town of Litomerice,
which is perhaps 45
minutes Northwest of Prague
in what today is the
Czech Republic in Bohemia
and the area that Hitler
called the Sudetenland
and the Czechs call the pohranicni,
the borderlands with Germany
and German speaking areas.
And I began here in no small measure
because this town was, and
Bohemia more generally,
was kind of a seriously contested site
during the reformation
and even before that
in terms of Christianity and
played host for many years,
for centuries to a Jesuit
seminary, and it's in this context
of a broader orbit of what I
call Catholic cosmopolitanism
that we see connections
between the Philippines
and this town in the person
of Ferdinand Blumentritt,
a man who corresponded closely
and expressed great sympathies and support
for José Rizal, the
great Philippine novelist
and nationalist icon in
the late 19th century
as he faced a series of trials
and tribulations in his last years,
including his eventual
execution by the Spaniards.
But here, although Litomerice
has its own history
in kind of Czech nationalist history,
I think what's interesting
is that Blumentritt himself
was no supporter of Czech nationalism.
He was a supporter of a
German liberal tradition
and envisaged and supported
a German liberal future
for Bohemia as part of a
broader German speaking kind
of context, as we know from
the Austro-Hungarian empire.
And yet his background and
his connections to Rizal
can be understood within
this broader orbit
of Catholic cosmopolitanism
that's so deeply rooted
in that setting that the Czech
saint, the Bohemian Saint
Jan Nepomucky, 14th
century saint is a sort
of common feature of many
sort of municipal plazas
and churches and of public
life in the Philippines
as in many other parts of the world known
as San Juan Nepomuceno, and in fact
one of the most prominent
political families in the province
of Pampanga that I recall
encountering 1987 when the uncle
of this fellow was assassinated.
The Nepomucceno family they're
a wealthy, powerful family
with a series of of supermarkets,
Nepo Marts around the province.
So there are traces of
Bohemian Catholicism
in the Philippines that go far
beyond the Jesuit seminary,
the gymnasium where Blumentritt taught
and the correspondence
between him and Rizal.
It's no coincidence as it were
in a similar but different vein,
I begin the five chapters
on the Indonesian Revolution
in the early 20th century oil boom context
of the city of Baku, today the capital
of the Azerbaijan Republic,
which in the early 20th century
was notable for a number
of distinctive features.
On the one hand, given the oil boom
it was one of the most
industrialized towns
or cities in the Muslim
world and in this way,
resembled Indonesia with its early forms
of industrialized wage, labor,
and industrial production,
especially in those areas
connected to port harbors
through railroads, linked up
to the great sugar plantations
of Java and parts of Sumatra at the time.
And Baku was like Indonesia by
the turn of the 20th century,
a hub for new forms of Islamic modernism
and expression and activism.
For example, the political
party Musavat that emerged
in the wake of the sort
of very tumultuous period
of World War I, but it was also a hub
for revolutionary socialism.
So Joseph Stalin, as we know him today,
spent a great deal of his
time in the early 1900s
as a kind of gangster
kidnapper revolutionary
and Lothario in Baku.
And we know that in the
aftermath of World War I
after a brief experiment
with an independent Azerbaijan
Republic that we find Baku
as a hub for Bolshevik propaganda
within and beyond the Russian Empire
with the 1920 Congress of
the Peoples of the East.
And what we can see here
that's quite interesting
is an effort to combine the
energies and aspirations
that we associate with revolutionary
socialism and communism
on the one hand and what was then
termed pan-Islam on the other.
At this Congress, the
Ukrainian Jew Grigory Zinoviev
calling for a jihad against,
that's the word he used,
against British and French imperialism.
Something that was taken up in the context
of growing awareness of
struggles among Muslim peoples
in far-flung places, far from Baku
that might be connected up
through communism and Islam.
And although there were no
representatives from Indonesia
at the time in 1920,
there were representatives
of the Communist Party of
Holland who would go on
to play an important role
in Indonesian history
and in the making of communism there.
And at the Congress, there
was a poem that was read out
slightly adulterated by the
Acmeist poet Sergei Gorodetsky
about the coffee plantations
and the exploitation of
plantation workers in Java.
So there was already in the
air some interest in Indonesia.
And indeed two years later
when they held a similar
Comintern Congress in Moscow
they invited Tan Malaka who had risen
to take over the Communist
Party of Indonesia
founded in 1920, and he spoke briefly
about the possibilities
of linking up communism
and pan-Islam as it was then called
before he was kind of rudely interrupted.
And if you read the stenographic notes,
you'll see he was kind of
forcibly basically shut up
and forced off the stage
as this was not convenient.
And just as he became subsequently
marginalized, likewise,
the the local head of the
so-called Muslim Commission
within the People's
Commissariat for Nationalities
headed by Stalin, Mirsaid
Sultan-Galiev with his aspirations
for Muslim communism disappeared,
not only marginalized
but eventually imprisoned in the gulags
and executed years later.
So we can see in Baku
the early possibility
but then the failed kind of consummation
of a possible alliance between
forces acting in the name
of revolutionary socialism
or communism on the one hand
and Islam on the other,
something that's crucial
for understanding the
Indonesian Revolution.
And finally, if we take
the Vietnamese revolution,
which I treat in the final three chapters
of the book before the conclusion,
I begin much more predictably
in the Southern Chinese city of Guangzhou,
which is often referred
to in the 19th centuries
and earlier as Canton in Western sources.
And this is probably more
understandable or obvious
as a move given the close connections
that I'll talk about
between what becomes Vietnam
and Guangzhou in Southern
China more generally,
but it's also understandable
in the sense that Guangzhou was
as some have described it,
the cradle of the revolution in China.
It's after all, the city from
which or at least around which
we see the great luminaries
of the late 19th centuries,
Chinese intellectual revolutions
Kang Youwei and Liang Qichao.
If we think of Sun Yat-sen,
he comes from a family
that immigrates from Guangdong Province
and from the Pearl River Delta.
And he ends up back in Guangzhou
heading up a nationalist government
after the first Chinese
Revolution that overthrew
the Qing dynasty, such
that when Ho Chi Minh,
as we now know him, arrived
in Guangzhou in 1924
he found it, the city as
the hub and the capital
of the nationalist government
trying to reclaim China,
but also as a hub for
various forms of experiments
with radical politics.
It's in Guangzhou where you see
the Hong Kong-Canton Seamen's
Strike being carried out
with sympathy and support and solidarity.
It's in Guangzhou that we
see the short-lived commune
after the breakdown of the Kuomintang
Chinese Communist Party Alliance in 1927.
It's in Guangzhou that we see the Whampoa
or Huangpu Military Academy
with Soviet advisors training
nationalists and communists
and some Vietnamese military
cadets for military training
in ways that proved crucial
for the Chinese and
Vietnamese revolutions.
And it's also, interestingly
enough, around Guangzhou
that we see the first Chinese
Communist Party experiments
with peasant organizing
under the leadership
of a man named Peng Pai
with the Peasant Movement
Training Institute
where Mao Zedong first began to articulate
and undertake peasant organizing
intellectual activities,
something that Vietnamese
activists were drawn into as well.
So it's pretty obvious why
I would start in Guangzhou.
And so I'm perhaps sounding
a little bit more sensible
for Southeast Asianists, but
here just to confuse things
a bit, I also include in the introduction
to these Vietnamese chapters,
the chapters in the Vietnamese
Revolution a discussion
of the city once known as Tananarive,
now as Antananarivo, the
capital of Madagascar
because it's worth noting
that in the early aftermath
of World War I or during
World War I itself
the 100,000 Vietnamese
soldiers and workers
who are drawn to France and Europe
to support the French war
effort, find themselves
with hundreds of thousands
of more African soldiers
and workers, and some Chinese soldiers
and workers as well, or at least workers.
And they mix and mingle with
them and get drawn into forms
of political activism that are
significant and are enabling
and encouraging forms of
activism that take on a life
of their own in other parts
of the world, as we'll see.
And there's a kind of reprise
of this linkage in 1947,
really the darkest, most difficult year
for the Viet Minh as
they're fighting the French.
And it's happily enough for them the year
where there's an
insurrection in Madagascar
that distracts French troops
and draws French troops away
to put down very brutally
and violently an insurrection
in this African Island and
French colony at the time.
So in other words, I'm trying to evoke
the kind of entanglement
of Vietnam's revolution
with a broader arc of
developments and trends
that extend not only to neighboring China,
no big news there, perhaps,
but also extrapolating a bit
in terms of an African connection as well.
Okay, so, so far so confusing
and so far from Southeast Asia
but just to reassure you,
there's a kind of method
to the madness, and much of the action
and much of the point really
has to do with Southeast Asia.
I can promise you that.
And here, I think the argument
that I'm making is framed
for this audience and
for the book as a whole,
not for scholars of revolution,
not for political scientists
but for people interested
in Southeast Asian studies.
And it's framed in the
context of what seemed to me
to be two crucial distinctive features
of Southeast Asian studies,
especially in that kind
of Cornell-Yale nexus
or axis or corridor that
Erik was mentioning.
And it seems to me that the
two distinctive features
of Southeast Asian
studies that I'm writing
in the context of and
in some measure against
are as follows, first of
all a tendency to kind of,
what's the word, a kind of
preoccupation with the notion
of the autonomy and in John Smail's terms,
an authenticity of Southeast
Asia and Southeast Asians
rather than an understanding
of Southeast Asia as a kind of,
you know, poor man's or
poor woman's kind of version
of a bigger, better
civilization next door,
whether in India or in China.
In other words, a notion that in order
to study Southeast Asia, we don't want
to be second-rate,
third-rate Orientalists.
We want to claim that
there's something distinctive
about Southeast Asia, and
you can't understand it
if you just think that
it's a cheap imitation
of something from beyond.
And this preoccupation
is evident if we think
of O.W. Wolters' famous
account of Khmer Hinduism
where he tells us that Khmer Hinduism
is as Khmer as it is Hindu.
Clifford Geertz's account
of religion on Java,
that Islam is as Javanese as
it is anything else on Java,
and Vince Rafael's account
of what's gained and lost
in the translation of Spanish Catholicism
and Latin Roman Catholicism into Tagalog
in the early period of
Spanish colonial rule
in the Philippines in the
16th and 17th centuries.
So this is one kind of
preoccupation that I think
is very striking about
Southeast Asian studies.
And the second is a
preoccupation with nationalism.
And here I'm about a preoccupation
that's there very much
in the '60s and '70s and
'80s in the Cold War era
in which scholars of Southeast Asia
opposed to US involvement in Indochina,
opposed to various forms of
US intervention in the region
are understandably
concerned to argue and show
how various forms of
anti-imperialism in Southeast Asia
are reflective of authentic
forms of nationalism,
rather than just a bunch
of fellow travelers
or communists in disguise.
And so there's a great deal
of energy and effort devoted
to the analysis of
nationalism in Southeast Asia.
And it's in this context,
this Cold War context,
it seems to me, that we see
the production and publication
by Benedict Anderson of the
single most interesting,
important, and insightful
book that we have
about nationalism in general,
"Imagined Communities."
And it seems to me that since
the publication of this book
in 1983, it's worth
noting, with opening pages
that really emphasize the Cold War context
in which it's written, the
so-called Second Cold War
under Ronald Reagan
before Mikhail Gorbachev
assumes office in Moscow
that we see the creation
of a kind of template
for understanding Southeast Asian history,
a template that came to
be dominant by the end
of the 20th century in the
study of Southeast Asia.
And this template sort
of works as follows,
fairly clearly and coherently,
and here concisely, namely
that we see from the relative
incoherence and fuzziness
of loosely structured dynastic realms
up into the 19th century,
we see with the rise of
modern, mostly colonial states
in the late 19th and early 20th century
the creation of administrative structures
and then parallel school
systems and languages
of state that enable the
emergence and expansion of forms
of shared experience,
expression, understanding,
self-understanding, and consciousness
that are proto-nationalist and enable
and impel nationalist
forms of mobilization
and then give rise to new nation states
by the mid-late 20th century.
And so this creates for us
and has established quite conveniently
for people teaching
Southeast Asian history
a kind of neat template for understanding,
a kind of teleology for understanding
modern Southeast Asian history.
- But this template, it seems to me,
raises two questions
which can't be answered
within its own terms,
within this template itself.
First of all, how can
we explain the variance
that we observe in the
pathways to independence?
Especially revolutions on the one hand
in their different forms,
in different timing,
different varying success on the one hand
and on the other much
more staged managed forms
of de-colonization leading
to something more closely
like neo-colonial forms
of pseudo independence.
So for example, Lee Kuan Yew
famously derided Malaysia
as having one independence
because they were delivered it
on a silver platter by British royalty
with a bed of roses rather
than fighting for it
in a kind of heroic fashion.
Sharp contrast with Vietnam also.
But then secondly, and probably
even more problematically,
or more obviously problematic
even for historians
rather than these damn
political scientists, is this.
When and where we do see mass mobilization
and revolutionary mass
mobilization, how can we explain it
when Anderson has told
us that the broad mass
of the population couldn't
possibly be nationalists
at the time of revolutionary
mobilization, right?
I mean, although Anderson's
book tells us that nationalism
is interesting and
important, it also tells us
that there's a hell of a lot
less nationalism historically
among far fewer people
than we otherwise previously
would have imagined.
The people who are
nationalists are going to look
like these men, they're gonna be male.
They're gonna be educated.
And in the Southeast Asian contexts
they are basically the kind of dandies
and flaneurs who we associate
with a certain social class
because it's only these kinds
of mostly men who by the turn
of the 20th or the mid-20th
century will be Andersonian
in terms of their education
and socialization and immersion
in those circuitries of
nationalist socialization
and consciousness that he
tells us are so necessary
for people to be nationalists
in the first place.
So what about the
so-called unwashed masses?
The broad mass of the population
that didn't go to school,
that remained illiterate, unsocialized
didn't see the maps on
the school room walls
or circulate through those circuitries
of the colonial state, what about them?
How did they get mobilized at all?
How was it possible?
And here, it seems to me
that there's a tendency
in the literature to kind
of link and kind of marry
the kind of Andersonian
elite account with a kind
of account of mass
participation that harks back
to the first distinctive feature
of Southeast Asian studies
I mentioned earlier, namely what we see
in Reynaldo Ileto's book
"Pasyon and Revolution"
where he suggests that there
were distinctively Tagalog
or Filipino conceptions
of Kalayaan or freedom
which animated the
participation in the Katipunan
in the Philippine Revolution.
Or in Ben Anderson's earlier book,
"Java in a Time of Revolution"
with its great cover here.
Some of you might recognize
Amrih Widodo in the photo there.
And here Anderson, he's talking about
how a distinctly Javanese
conception of power
informed the Pemuda,
the youth who were drawn
into participation and leadership
in sort of spearheading the Revolution.
Or we can take in the case of
Vietnam, this wonderful quote
from Alexander Woodside in his book,
"Community and Revolution
in Modern Vietnam"
claiming that no amount
of statistics, rhetoric,
or social science theory can explain
the Vietnamese revolution adequately
if its properties of acute
historical consciousness
and cultural pride are
insufficiently considered.
So in other words, that
it was this deep sense
of shared Vietnamese identity
and culture and history
and community that
animated mass participation
among ordinary Vietnamese, peasants,
and participants in the revolution.
But it seems to me that
these sorts of accounts
and their linkage to a kind
of Andersonian elite account
is inadequate or problematic in terms
of where it leaves us
descriptively and analytically.
In descriptive terms,
it raises the question
of what Jim Scott used to call
the revolution within the revolution.
How is it that the commissars
managed the peasants
in these revolutions?
How is it that the miscommunications
and misrepresentations
in this kind of split level
of revolution in which elites
and masses are thinking in such
different terms was managed?
Clearly very problematic.
It also raises questions
in explanatory terms.
How then could we explain
the variance that we see
in which some revolutions
unfold and others don't
and some revolutions
head in some directions
and assume some forms and
other take different ones?
And finally, I think, a recent book
by someone who I saw is in
the audience, Christian Lentz,
on Dien Bien Phu, the famous battle
that is kind of a signifier
for anticolonial nationalist,
independent struggles.
He shows in his dissertation
and then in his recently
published book that in fact
the thousands of Coolie laborers
who played such a crucial role
in making the Vietnamese Communist Party,
the Viet Minh's victory possible
alongside the participation
of Chinese military advisers
and military assistance,
weren't even ethnic Vietnamese
or Vietnamese speakers themselves.
And they are whom we would describe
as ethnic minorities today instead.
So in other words, this
picture of this template
that I've suggested leaves
some key questions unanswered.
And it's in the kind of
go-to response and supplement
and corrective to this kind
of a gap in the template,
it seems to me is also inadequate.
So against this backdrop the book,
"Republican, Communism,
Islam" as the title suggests
offers a different template.
Not a contradictory template,
but a complimentary template.
And one that's not by any
stroke of imagination original,
but it's rather a composite synthesis
of at least three decades of
scholarship by historians,
some of whom are graduates
of Yale University.
I can see there's Kevin
Fogg in the audience,
and his recently published
book, Rianne Subijanto
who's a PhD and
soon-to-be-published book are,
these are important
works in a broader trend
in the literature, which
tells us something different.
And if you add them all
up beginning with perhaps
Chris Gosha's work on Vietnam,
Mike Laffan's work on
Indonesia, you begin to see
a different kind of
picture coming into view.
And I'm really just drawing
together these strands
into a composite picture
with some comparative analysis as well.
And here, the emphasis is not
on the rise of modern states
and the emergence of nationalism
but instead on long-distance commerce,
capitalist development,
and cosmopolitan connections
and connectedness.
And so we see up into the early modern era
that rising long-distance trade gives rise
to various forms of cosmopolitanism.
There's the so-called Sanskrit Cosmopolis
that Sheldon Pollock writes about.
There's the Arabic Cosmopolis
that Ronit Ricci writes about.
There's so-called
Sinographic cosmopolitanism
for Vietnam in particular.
there is obviously Islamic cosmopolitanism
beyond Arabic cosmopolitanism,
and there is also a Catholic
cosmopolitanism as well
through the early modern era.
And what I suggest in the
book is that the legacies
of these forms of cosmopolitanism
are in some measure
determinant of the
trajectories and outcomes
of the revolutionary
mobilizations that we see
in Southeast Asia centuries later
at the turn of the 20th
century in the Philippines
and in the mid-20th century
in Indonesia and Vietnam.
But really it's the transportation
and communication revolutions
of the mid-late 19th century
and the deepening
integration of Southeast Asia
into the world economy
in the mid 20th century
that overshadows the
older cosmopolitanisms
and overlays them with new ones
in concrete institutional forms
which provide infrastructures
for mobilization.
So it's during this period
that we see the emergence
of Southeast Asian cities,
their linkage up to market towns
and the creation of market societies.
And crucially, the tightening
integration of Southeast Asia
into the world economy
doesn't just couple colonies
and metropoles into ever more intimate,
intense dyadic embraces
but opens the flood gates
to more diverse influences.
In the Philippine archipelago,
the port cities are opened
and German and British
and other firms come in
that dwarf Spanish commerce.
In the Dutch East Indies,
many of the big plantations
on Java and Sumatra are not Dutch owned,
but owned by other European companies.
And Singapore remains an
important hub for Indies trade
up until the late 19th century.
If we take the case of French Indochine,
much of the commodities flow
to, especially rice flow
to Southern China, and
some of the profits flow
into French Imperial investments
in various parts of Africa.
The mercantile classes that
emerge in Southeast Asia
are of course in considerable
measure of immigrant stock
whether Chinese from Fujian
and Guangdong provinces,
Indian like the Chettiars, or Arab
from the Hadhramaut region
of what today is Yemen.
So in other words, what we see alongside
the kind of Andersonian nationalizing
or proto-nationalizing trends
is something very
cosmopolitan in its forms.
And we can see this in
the distinctively hybrid
and cosmopolitan forms
of popular entertainment,
popular opera, popular
forms of entertainment
that we see in the cities
and towns of Southeast Asia.
The Komedi Stamboel in the Indies
and in the Malay peninsula,
which traces its roots back to Bombay.
Cai luong in what's now Vietnam,
which has diverse Chinese
and Western influences in
terms of music and expression,
or the Komedia that we
see in the Philippines.
After all, the most famous epic poem
of the 19th century in Tagalog literature,
it is about a series of
events that take place
in Albania of all places.
So in other words, what we see
by the turn of the 20th
century in Southeast Asia
is the emergence of very
cosmopolitan sort of cities
and towns with a cosmopolitan,
very diverse mercantile
and professional classes,
new forms of modern learning,
knowledge, schooling, and
associational activity,
new forms of modernity
in terms of expression
and associational activity,
forms of modern consciousness.
And so this template suggests this kind
of teleology instead,
but leaving open a realm
of indeterminacy as to when,
where, how, or whether at all
it will lead to some form
of revolution making.
And so throughout much of
the book, what I try and do
is to hold together an
underlying framework
of a kind of comparative
historical sociological analysis
even while emphasizing the importance
of major international conjunctures.
The Spanish American
War, the Sino-Japanese
and Russo-Japanese Wars, World War I
and of course, World War II.
But the real thrust of
the analysis in the book
lies in a more structuralist kind
of comparative historical sociology
with an emphasis on the variance
in how these different
Southeast Asian societies
played host to different kinds
and different constellations
of cosmopolitan linkages
which provided institutional,
organizational, and discursive
bases for different kinds
of revolutionary mobilization
as signaled in the title,
"Republicanism, Communism, Islam."
And there are two essential
elements in the argument
along the lines of comparative
historical sociology.
The first is that the early
modern era gave rise to forms
of cosmopolitanism that left legacies
in terms of scholasticism and
scholastic infrastructures
that we see whether Catholic
or Islamic or sinographic
which are important in
their varying tendencies
towards absorption and
integration, into existing orders
and state structures or
autonomy and independence
and evolution and expansion
outside of the state
or evisceration by modern colonial states.
And this matters in due course.
And the second thing that
really matters is what happens
in the late 19th and early 20th century
in terms of class formation,
in terms of the emergence
of dominant classes and
subaltern classes that vary
in different ways in terms
of their sort of capacities
to serve as social bases
for different kinds of
revolutionary projects
and forms of revolutionary mobilization.
And I had initially
planned to then go through
this kind of account for
the three revolutions,
but I can see that time is
short and that if I proceed
along those lines, I will not
leave much time for questions.
So I can just give you
some choice quotes here
from the concluding chapter of the book
that give you a flavor of
the conclusions I draw.
This is a kind of a little
nugget of a concluding argument.
But if we look at the
account of the Philippines,
this is where I come down
in terms of emphasizing
the importance of an
underlying tension and conflict
between an assimilated
Chinese Mestizo dominant class
that combines economic,
social, and political power
on a local level and runs
up against, increasingly,
the entrenched powers
of the Catholic Church
in the late 19th century and
has the capacity to articulate
and to lead forms of
mobilization in tune with
and in sync with similar
kinds of struggles
going on in other parts
of the Catholic world
in the late 19th century,
the so-called culture
Wars between ultramontane,
very conservative Catholicism
and various strands
of republicanism and
liberalism represented
by Freemasonry most particularly.
And that this is crucial in
terms of the infrastructure
for mobilization and in terms
of when and where and how
and by whom we see this
kind of mobilization.
It's something that that I trace up
into the revolution
itself, so that the figure
of Andres Bonifacio, a
key leader in the making
of the Katipunan, the
fact that he is working
for a German company
in Manila's Chinatown,
the fact that he had served
as an actor in a local Komedia
and the fact that among his
books is the famous book,
"The Wandering Jew"
which depicts the Jesuits
as part of this elaborate
conspiracy are all symptomatic,
emblematic of this broader
pattern of what made
and also what limited
the Philippine Revolution
in terms of the limitations
of its egalitarian promise
and its capacity for
organizational sort of solidity
in the face of various challenges.
The Katipunan within the Katipunan.
And of course the massive
might of the American military
as they invaded and
occupied the Philippines
at the turn of the 20th century.
By contrast, if we look
at the Indonesian case,
the emphasis is on two features
of the Indonesian archipelago
that distinguish it
from the Philippines and
other parts of Southeast Asia.
The first is the notable
autonomy or independence
of various forms of Islamic schooling
and associational activity
which render it available
for forms of mobilization
already in the early 20th century
and during the Revolution.
And then on the other hand,
the importance and extent
of large-scale plantation agriculture
and railroad transport, and the creation
of a large scale wage labor
based industrial proletariat
providing the basis for
left-wing socialist,
communist labor organizing and
mobilization with communist
and Islamic infrastructures
proving so crucial
for mobilization in the Revolusi
in the latter half of the 1940s
as shown so brilliantly by
Kevin Fogg in his recent book.
So I think that without Islam
and communism often derided
by official nationalist
accounts as somehow traitors
to the revolution, without
Islam and communism
the Revolusi would have
had very little oomph to it
in terms of the the energies
that it brought to the Revolution.
And yet the failure of those two
kind of cosmopolitan rubrics
for mobilization to combine
and fuse in a single form also
limited their effectiveness
and rendered them vulnerable
to absorption, appropriation
and eventual evisceration
by a Republican state after independence.
And finally, in the Vietnamese case,
what I suggest is another
point of comparison,
if we can get down to it.
You see how much I hoped
to go through here.
And the crucial thing in the
Vietnamese case is twofold.
One, that the form of
sinographic cosmopolitanism
that had lasted on and off for centuries
in Vietnamese history die
a a death just a decade
after their disappearance
in neighboring China
with the forms of sinographic
learning and schooling
and socialization that previously fed
into an imperial state abolished
as a new form of state rule emerges.
And so the elimination
of this kind of tradition
and this kind of infrastructure
for mobilization,
for socialization,
communication, and mobilization
that lasted into the early
20th century in Vietnam.
It's elimination meant that in Vietnam,
you didn't have a kind of
institutional counterweight
that would provide an
alternative basis to communism
in the way that the Islamic schools
and associations did in the Indies.
And also crucially the tight integration
of the Vietnamese economy into
the Southern Chinese economy
really rendered the local Vietnamese,
and the insistence of the
French colonial regime
on segregating Chinese immigrants
really rendered the local
Vietnamese business class
a small marginal potential
carrier for and social base
for a Republican alternative
to other forms of mobilization
and other kinds of egalitarian promise
and discourse and
revolutionary brotherhood.
And this combined with the
circumstances and the geography
of Vietnam within Indochina
within the French empire
and of course as a neighbor
of China really disadvantaged
alternatives and
challengers to what became
the monolithic monopoly of the Viet Minh
and the Communist Party over
the revolutionary struggle.
And so it's this kind
of comparative analysis
combined with an attention
to international conjunctures
and various forms of sympathy,
support, and solidarity
in different parts of the
world that provides the canvas
for the accounts I give
these revolutions and the way
in which I roll out this
initial template into an account
of the trajectories and
outcomes of these revolutions,
providing a kind of
denationalized, internationalized,
and trans-nationalized account
of revolutions in Southeast Asia.
Sorry for going on for so long,
but there may be many
questions about the book,
and the good news is you can read the book
and you can also purchase the
book at a serious discount
and get all the answers there.
So thank you and sorry for going over.
- Thank you, John.
No need to apologize at all.
It was a fascinating talk.
I'm sure we're gonna
have a lot of questions.
I'm going to stop sharing the screen
just so that we can all
see each other's faces
and create a little bit of
community here during the Q&A.
So everyone, please raise your
hand, use the hand function.
And if you can't figure
out how to do that,
send me a text through the chat function
or wave your hand wildly,
and eventually I'll see you.
But let's start with whoever
has the first question.
I'd also like, Kevin has a question.
I was about to mention Kevin's name.
I wanted to invite both
Kevin and Christian Lentz
to share their book links.
Out of modesty, they probably
won't want to do that,
but they were both called
out in the lecture.
So I give them permission
to share their links
to their books, to the rest of us
'cause I'm sure a lot of people-
- I can pull copies off my shelves.
- So we'll start with
Kevin, and then the question
from Christian right
after that, and then...
- Well, that's very kind of you, Erik.
And thank you, John, so much
for a really interesting engagement.
The question that I
wondered, and I'm not sure
that the book goes this far is about some
of the near misses in Southeast Asia.
You, I don't want to say derided,
but you quoted Lee Kuan Yew
to deride the Malaysian cases,
getting handed independence
on a silver platter,
but they did have a quote
unquote emergency for 10 years.
They did have folks who wanted
a revolutionary direction.
You know, there are other
countries in Southeast Asia
where this could have happened,
and there are also ways
in which the countries
that we wound up with.
I mean, Indonesia might not
have wound up as Indonesia.
It could have wound up as
two things or as five things.
I, as a historian, there's
some worry when we look
at this big structural
thing that you've accepted
the structures that came after
and then gone back to explain them
instead of wondering what
could have happened otherwise.
Do you talk at all about the near misses
or the contingencies in this
and where that might have gone for others?
- Should I go ahead and answer
individual questions, Erik?
- Yeah, please do.
- Okay, it's a great question.
I mean, they're in a way,
two elements of an answer.
One is that I do extend very
briefly in the conclusion
the analysis to cover other
countries in Southeast Asia.
So I take Indonesia and
then look at Malaysia
and say, well, yes, on the one hand,
we see a very impressive form
of Malayan Communist Party mobilization
and insurrectionary activity that lasts
from the late '40 into the 1950s,
but it's limited in considerable measure.
Revisionist historians question
this, but in large measure
to the Chinese population
and to certain segments
of the population in
terms of social class.
And I think that a
contrast in terms of Islam
is also very strong that you can see
that in contrast with
Indonesia where you have,
basically Islam is left outside
the control of the colonial state.
It's not controlled by
the local aristocracy.
That's very different under
British colonial rule.
And you have nothing like
the kind of infrastructure
of autonomous, independent,
mobilizational capacity.
And you have also a very
different form of class formation.
The Javanese peasantry compared
to the Malay peasantry, very different.
So there is that, I do play
out that structuralist analysis
in terms of the comparison.
Now to get to your, you're
not a proper historian,
you're just one of these
damn political scientists
who are retrospectively
cherry picking the history
and avoiding the kind
of alternative moments and conjunctures.
So I do talk about the Sarekat Islam,
and there is new scholarship
coming out about that
and about that period.
And you yourself are working
on these possibilities
for sort of combining Islam and communism.
And I do dwell quite
a bit on that and how,
if not fully, why it doesn't happen.
Like the nature and extent to which
it begins to come together
and then it unravels.
And it happens across the 20th century
in many different contexts.
And, you know, if Ali
Shariati had not died
just before the Iranian revolution
would things have gone differently?
We don't have, you know, it
seems to be a broader pattern.
So I kind of end up at least
giving some time and space
to the woulda coulda shouldas
if not at least dwell on them.
- Thank you.
- Erik, should I go ahead?
- Yeah, thanks, John, I was
just going to ask Christian
to ask his question, please do.
- Well first let me just say, I think
as I just said to Eric in a chat
I'm still blushing, John, for
your nice call out of my book,
and it's very kind of you to mention that.
I'm also quite honored to be
mentioned in the same breath
as Kevin Fogg, my colleague
here at North Carolina.
So I had sort of one comment
perhaps and then one question.
My comment is, I think in
some ways it seems to me,
I just happened to finish
"Under Three Flags" yesterday,
Ben Anderson's final monograph
about the sort of anarchism
and its role in Southeast Asian history.
And so it seems to me
what you're doing then
is you're sort of bringing
this sort of late Anderson
into dialogue with early Anderson
and his work in "Imagined
Communities" to try and,
it was a work of synthesis
then rather than a rejection
of that earlier sort of, as you called it,
template for national consciousness.
That's I guess my comment.
And then my question is, all
of us who have gone to Yale
and Cornell again, I'm just
referring to the shout out
from Erik before, are
well aware that our field
of Southeast Asian studies came of age
in the United States during the Cold war.
And so I think there is,
as you suggest, an argument
for the kind of nationalist reading
of Southeast Asian history
as a way to counter
the American Imperial
project to put it quickly.
So given that we are now in
this different moment, right,
what do you think are
the essential ingredients
for this revisiting of
Southeast Asian studies?
Are we all now under the,
sort of the lure, if you will,
of globalization to try and
think about Southeast Asia
in a more decentered way?
What do you think are this sort
of fundaments, if you will,
of the intellectual situation
that are contributing to this revision?
Thank you.
- Great questions.
In terms of Ben Anderson's
"Under Three Flags,"
I mean, I've been working on this project
since, embarrassingly since 2003.
And he was aware of what I was
doing and I think, you know,
and he was supportive of it.
So it was not written, the
book is dedicated to him
and it is not written against him.
And I actually, there's a great quote
from "Under Three Flags"
that I included in the book
because the readers, the
reviewers of the manuscript said,
"You know, there's, we're not completely."
One of them at least said,
"I'm not fully comfortable with the way
in which you're engaging
with and framing this book."
And there was a bit of concern about that.
So I think I make clear
that I'm, you know,
that it's the template
rather than the book.
And that to go back to
Kevin's question of,
well, could Indonesia
have looked different?
Those sorts of issues, I
think that there's a kind
of impressive longevity
to imagine communities
in terms of almost an implicit
or explicit prediction
that these nations will stay as such
in terms of their boundaries.
And so I think, you know,
if you're interested
in those sorts of questions,
with the interesting rickles
which Chris Gosha offers
in the case of Indochina,
you know, I would say,
I fully endorse that.
It is the template.
And so to get to your final question,
I think if we are going to not
be so concerned with saying,
oh, Southeast Asians are
ineffably Southeast Asian
in some way or Southeast Asians
are really deeply
nationalists in some way,
but instead we're gonna
do kind of global history
or world history then it's
important to make sure
that Southeast Asians are
seen as actors in this.
And there's a wonderful PhD thesis
from the University of Hawaii
which shows how it's not only
as scholars tell us that the
first globalization began
in Manila with the
connection of Asian, American
and European trade made
possible through the galleon,
but it's that Filipino
shipbuilders, Filipino loggers,
Filipino workers who
repaired and built ships
and then Filipino sailors who
navigated these ships back
across the Pacific, they
played a crucial role.
And so it's not just that
Manila was like a kind of,
you know, a site for this
but that Filipinos were
active, crucial participants.
It didn't just happen in Southeast Asia.
And so, you know, I think
it's crucial for the accounts
to show the active creative
roles of Southeast Asians
making the most if not always
the best of globalizations.
And I guess in political terms,
for me that maybe something
that somehow still stays with me is in,
I don't know, was it 2010,
the election here in the UK,
all three very conventional
and conservative politicians
when asked, who were
running for prime minister
when asked who they
admired most in the world
they also said, oh, Nelson Mandela,
Nelson Mandela, Nelson Mandela.
And so Nelson Mandela is cute and cuddly
as a kind of hero struggling
for South African nationalism
as it were, but the fact
that he was supported by
if not a member of the South
African Communist Party,
that rendered him untouchable.
And no one would shake
his hand or ask for him
to get out of jail all those
long years in the 20th century.
So it's quite hypocritical
and a convenient forgetfulness
for us to forget the role
of the the communists
and the Islamists, or the
role of communism and Islam
in the making of the
Indonesian Revolution,
of all sorts of inconvenient people
in the making of the Vietnamese
Revolution as you show us.
So I think to denationalize can be helpful
because I think we've seen a
great deal of renationalisation
and recentralization of
power in different parts
of the world in the past 10, 20 years.
In Russia, in China, in Turkey,
in India, in the United States.
Like, why not continue
to work to denationalize?
Yeah.
- John, I'm gonna jump in with a question.
I see that Kelvin has a question,
but I didn't see the hand until right now.
And I've already started
asking my question technically
so I'll forge ahead and then
Kelvin will be right after.
I wanted to ask you a
little bit about this term
that you used, scholasticism,
exactly what you mean by that.
And it may be a term of art that I just,
I'm not up on the language.
And how you call that a certain kind
of cosmopolitan connection,
and how you might differentiate that
from Ben Anderson's famous
points about print capitalism
because it seems that it's also
a kind of cosmopolitan connection.
And I'm wondering, are you arguing
against the formative
role of print capitalism?
Or are you trying to say
that there are other forms
of cosmopolitan connections
that are sort of,
we ignore them when we
pay too much attention
to a certain kind of cosmopolitanism?
And I also wanted to use
this as an opportunity
to make a mention of next week's Brown Bag
because Kathleen Gutierrez's
work on botany is actually,
it sounds to me like it's
actually unexpectedly
doing the same kind of thing
that you're talking about
because she talks about how
through the rise of botany
in the Philippines there's a kind
of botanical cosmopolitanism that emerges.
And there was a concept of
Southeast Asia that she describes
called Malesia which was a floristic zone,
like a floristic region among
the scientific community.
And so I think there's a kind
of unexpected convergence
there, and also some other,
the scholarship that recently been out,
in Claire Eddington's work
on colonial psychiatry
talks a lot about how the psychiatrists
in colonial Indochine were looking
to the Dutch psychiatrists to get ideas
about how to create new asylums
and those kinds of things.
So there's an interesting
emergence of the scholarship
that seems to be doing what you're doing
but without the kind of nice framework
that you're giving it to.
And so I wanted to signal
that, remind everyone to come
to next week's Brown Bag and
also just ask you to clarify
the difference between the scholasticism
and your form of cosmopolitan connection
and that famous idea of print capitalism.
- Okay, great question.
So if you look at "Imagined
Communities" you'll see
that Ben Anderson talks about
kind of pre-national forms
of cosmopolitan consciousness
that he associates
with sacred languages that one might link
to very broad transoceanic
trends, continental
kind of religious communities,
whether it's Latin
or Pali or Arabic, classical
Arabic, or classical Chinese.
And I guess what I see as
significant is much more specific,
namely the institutions of
scholarly or scholastic activity
that we see in terms of seminaries,
in terms of what turn into
the madrassas or the Pesantren
over centuries and their
counterparts in Vietnam
that are analogous and interrelated
to what's happening in
China in terms of every year
and these patterns of
circulation and connectedness
that are sociologically quite
interesting and important
because, you know, if in
village schools there are people
studying "The Four
Books and Five Classics"
and then they go to the town
and then they go to the bigger market town
and then they go to the provincial capital
and eventually they go to Hui
for the exams, that is a form
of connectedness over
decades and centuries
that you then would see
with Islamic counterparts
or in terms of Catholic
schools and seminaries.
And that's very important, I think.
It is notably almost all male.
So it's similar to Anderson's emphasis
on kind of school boy
nationalism in a way.
But I think that these kinds
of connectedness, they,
regardless of the content,
they have different forms
and they have different histories
in terms of what happens to them.
They evolve and attach
themselves into states.
And then they die if the
state dispenses with them
as we see in Vietnam.
In the case of Islam,
they evolve and evolve
and survive outside of the state.
And we see in the case of Catholicism,
that they evolve in diverse
and conflicted directions.
So I think that it's important
to trace those histories
because I think that they vary
in ways that are important
for these revolutions
and for these societies.
So that's what I mean by these sorts of,
so they're pre-modern
forms of cosmopolitanism
and scholasticism that
then evolve with modernity
and with their new experiments,
with Islamic modernism,
Islamic reformism, that
even the Dominicans decide
they have to teach medicine
and science in the late 19th century
which the Jesuits are
doing decades earlier.
So I think that's what I mean.
And that's what I emphasize in the book.
So it's a bit of that kind of,
it's a bit like the Southeast
Asian studies. (laughs)
- That's great.
I actually think that if you looked more
into Vietnamese Catholicism, too
although the numbers are not
the same for the Philippines
so they don't create the possibility
of total revolutionary transformation,
but some of the same
dynamics you're describing
also take place in Vietnamese Catholicism
and the kind of circulation
of a cosmopolitan network.
There's actually even a
secondary layer of almost
an alternative state system
with different counties,
like these parish-style
counties that totally give you
a different geography of what is known
as the nation of Vietnam.
But I'll let Kevin ask his question.
After Kevin we have a
question from Jennifer Gaynor.
And then after Jennifer, we'll
turn to Rianne Subijanto.
- Hi, Professor Sidel.
Thank you so much for your presentation
as well as for your book.
I thought it was really interesting.
And as someone working broadly on this
into a movement of various
internationalist projects,
I found just the ambition of your book
to be incredibly admirable.
I have a question which
is which really builds
on Professor Harms's question
on scholasticism and cosmopolitanism.
And I guess I'm really curious
about your use of the term cosmopolitanism
in relation to other terms
that may be in circulation
during this period.
So if you look at the
Kompeten and if you look
at the Baku Conference, I
believe that a term that most
of this cohort of Marxists was
using was internationalism.
And if you look the different
parts of Islam as modernism
and of pan-Islamism on the sub-continent
and in Southeast Asia,
the vision of universalism
that it posited was one of the Ummah,
as they took the Ummah as a sort
of spatial scale of reference.
And I guess the term
cosmopolitanism, as you mentioned,
in a different sort of
conceptualization seems
to be very linguistically bound.
So you have the Sanskrit cosmopolis.
You have the Arabic cosmopolis.
You have the Persian cosmopolis.
And I was wondering if you
could elaborate a bit more
about perhaps the
differences and similarities,
where they converge
and where they diverge,
these different scales of
thinking, theorizing universalism.
How is internationalism
perhaps a different
or similar project compared
to cosmopolitanism?
Analytically, what do
they open up in terms
of how we think about these projects?
And how would we think
about new role of language
in perhaps forging these new
links and in this late 19th,
early 20th century moment,
keeping in mind, for instance
what Ben Anderson in "Under
Three Flags" would describe
as the true internationalism
of the polyglot, right.
And I guess a related question to that
centers around this
really fascinating figure
in your first chapter of
Mirsaid Sultan-Galiev,
him being the so-called architect
of Muslim quote unquote national communism
in the Soviet union, in
his sort of resolution
of the Tatar Kirgisia
Central Asian question.
I was wondering to what extent
was, if Sultan-Galiev himself
attempted to think about the
minoritized status of Muslims
in the Soviet Union through the
frame of national communism,
he's implicitly positing
a sort of congruence
between the project of
internationalist communism
with one of nationalism on the other.
And so I guess to what
extent would that apply
to Southeast Asia where
nationalism and internationalism
rather than being opposed to one another
might actually be consonant
or congruent with each other
in the sort of Sultan-Galiev sense?
But thank you so much again
for your presentation.
- That's the most, that's
like the toughest question
anyone could could ever ask.
It's a really great question.
And I think my knowledge and skills
and theoretical sophistication
really constrained me
to really undertake a
kind of ambitious project
to kind of compare
cosmopolitanism, so called.
But I think you're absolutely
right in your suggestion
that they must vary considerably
in terms of what they really
consist of and comprise.
And I think most clearly
like in your comment
about Sultan-Galiev and of
communist internationalism
or Muslim national communism,
the nation state is part of it.
You know, in Sheldon Pollock's
or other versions of
the Sanskrit cosmopolis,
that there's a great deal of
attention to court culture
and court literature and so forth.
But there isn't a conception of anything
resembling like a broader community.
And that might also true
in forms of sinographic
so-called cosmopolitanism
where there's a conception
of civilized rather
than barbarian behavior
and of forms of propriety
and refinement and knowledge
that don't embrace a broader community
in the way that an Ummah might do.
So I think there is huge variance
in how these so-called
cosmopolitanisms operate.
And I'm painfully aware that
among political theorists
and scholars of international relations
and other disciplines that
the term cosmopolitanism
is used in many different ways.
And for me it's kind of faute de mieux
that I'm using it given the alternatives.
To use the term transnationalism
clearly doesn't suffice.
And I think it's worth
nodding back in the direction
of "Imagined Communities"
where Anderson himself
uses the term and to
begin with some attention
to the legacies of those pre-national
forms of connectedness.
So, you know, the book will
be disappointing to readers
with great theoretical
sophistication, I think.
- Far from it, it's not
disappointing at all.
I greatly, greatly enjoyed it.
- Okay, well, many thanks.
And thanks for the great question.
And you know, I'm glad
that there are other people
interested in Sultan-Galiev
because to go back
to Kevin Fogg's question, I think he's one
of these interesting kind
of also-rans of history
sort of like Tan Malaka in
terms of what he represented
in terms of possibilities,
even working under Stalin.
- Thank you.
Jennifer Gaynor, you had a question.
And then after Jennifer, we
will have Rianne Subijanto.
- First I just want to
say, thank you, John
for a wonderful talk, and I
can't wait to read the book.
So take anything I have to
say with a grain of salt
'cause I haven't read the book yet,
but I'm really looking forward to it.
And I'm sort of surprised
that you haven't mentioned
Takashi Shiraishi
in all this sort of influences on you
because his "Age in Motion"
feels like it's been a big influence
in the conceptualization of the project.
I don't know if that's true, but I mean,
who else could have brought
in not just Blumentritt
but taken us over to
Zinoviev and then Dorochevsky
and not just Guangzhou.
And I love the way,
I can't wait to read that kind of writing.
It sounds like it's really fun.
But I want to pick up on
something you just said
and follow up on Kelvin's comment.
You mentioned the legacies
of pre-national forums of connectedness.
And I'm just wondering,
in using, maybe we do need
to theorize cosmopolitanism
more explicitly and better
because it's a wonderful notion,
but I wonder to what degree
it does kind of reinscribe
the idea of a dichotomy between
the internal autonomous,
authentic Southeast Asia thing
versus this externally
generated cosmopolitanism idea
or whatever it is, mercantile expansion,
or various forms of connectedness
that have come outside in.
Like, this is a false
dichotomy in my eyes.
So I'm just wondering if
there's room in thinking
about the precursors to
these cosmopolitan linkages
for forms that maybe could
have started in Southeast Asia
and simultaneously linked up
to these cosmopolitanisms.
So that's one thing I wanted to mention.
And then the other thing,
since I'm here is just,
where were the women in these revolutions?
Or was the role of women just
sociologically incidental?
- Great questions.
I can see three core questions there.
The second I'm not fully sure I fully get,
but let me try at least two of them
and then get onto the middle one.
So in terms of Takashi Shiraishi,
he definitely is acknowledged
in the acknowledgements
as an important influence given
the course I took with him
as a graduate student
and the kind of panoramic
comparative historical
sociologically-informed account
he gave of modern Southeast Asian history.
But also, as you mentioned,
"An Age in Motion"
and that interest in Haji Misbach
and in the Sarekat Islam and
so forth, which as you know,
we'll see also is being revisited
by other scholars these days as well.
So I think that interest in
what did and didn't happen
between Islam and communism is there.
And in the book, I spent a lot
of time on the Sarekat Islam,
and there's a lot of Takashi
there, so that's there.
In terms of the question of gender
and of women in particular,
I think I belatedly realized
towards the end of the book
that there's an argument that
I would like to bring out
perhaps in an article
that kind of teases it
out more explicitly.
And that links back to this notion
of scholastic cosmopolitanism.
Insofar as these forms of pre-modern
and early modern scholasticism
are overwhelmingly male,
their survival or their
demise has implications
not only in terms of politics
but also in terms of gender.
And what I see as distinctive
in the Vietnamese Revolution
is that the demise of this
kind of infrastructure
by the 19 teens in
Vietnam opens up a field
of educational experience
and socialization
that doesn't have the kind
of male-only qualities
and restrictions on it that we see
in the Islamic schools and that we see
in the late 19th century
Philippines heavily as well.
And I think that if you look
at the Vietnamese Revolution,
the role of women is really striking.
I mean, we have so many different accounts
of the role of women and
women hold up half the sky.
The Vietnamese Revolution,
compared to what people
have been able to show about
20th century Indonesian
revolutionary or Filipino
left-wing politics,
I think there's a much
more impressive history
that shows that there
are implications here
in terms of women's participation.
So I think that's the story.
And if people have said, well, you know,
that the book suggests,
but it doesn't draw it out
with the kind of evidence that
I think I could glom together
for an article to make that
kind of comparative case
more explicitly and extensively.
But I think there's something
like that that is important
in terms of the different implications
of these different histories
for these institutions
of reproducing patriarchy and
male forms of male monopoly
on certain forms of knowledge,
religious knowledge and so forth.
In terms of the dangers of
a kind of cosmopolitanism
at the expense of, like that, oh,
all Southeast Asians are cosmopolitans
or like a kind of unidirectional account.
I mean, I guess in the
book what I'm trying to do
is to suggest that the ways
in which these societies
were constituted and
evolved had a lot to do
with various different external elements.
And what became Vietnamese,
what became Filipino,
what became Indonesian had
outside and inside intertwined.
So I think that's what
I'm trying to suggest
and maybe didn't articulate it well.
But I can see that I'm privileging
the coasts over the interiors.
There's a lot that's maybe
getting missed there, right?
And so it could be the pendulum
is swinging too far back in my account.
And the proof has to be in
the Southeast Asian pudding
in terms of, you know, I
guess my interest is less
and my confidence is
less in an understanding
of consciousness but rather
in some kind of sociology.
And so if we ask ourselves
how the people we read about
in Mary Steedly's account
of the Indonesian revolution
or in accounts of these
little towns in Tonkin,
in 1945, when they hear about independence
being declared in Hanoi.
How did these people, what
possibilities were there
for organizing and mobilizing?
And what possibilities were foreclosed
sociologically, institutionally?
That's what I feel more confident
is knowable, at least for me.
Yeah, okay, thank you.
- Thanks for this stimulating discussion.
Our last question will
be from Rianne Subijanto.
And I want to apologize,
I think I have misspelled
Rianne's name twice in my chat.
My eyes can't read my
tiny screen very well.
So apologies to you Rianne,
but you can have the last question.
- No problem, thank you so much.
Hi, John, it's very nice
to meet you finally.
- Same.
- And my question is,
thank you so much for the book, obviously.
It's brilliant and it
gives a fresh new pathways
for research in Southeast Asia.
And my question is on the
idea of cosmopolitanism.
And I was thinking here, what
makes it a cosmopolitanism?
And what you've mentioned
is cosmopolitanism
is forms of connectedness
and infrastructure.
So is it ideology?
Because when we think about ideology,
which is what you talk about also, right.
Of course you talk about
the infrastructure.
They are traces of nationalism
or what I like to say,
parochialism instead of nationalism
in Islam and communism, right?
And also nationalism is very
much cosmopolitan in a sense
that it is a template that's
become copied elsewhere.
So I was thinking that maybe instead
of thinking of cosmopolitanism
versus nationalism,
we're thinking about
cosmopolitanism versus parochialism.
And then what makes it cosmopolitanism,
is it maybe, is it also material?
Because then if we think of it as material
in terms of shipping
lines, infrastructure,
of context, media, and language,
then we can trace those
in terms of the nature of those contexts
because in the history
of Indonesian communism
in the early 1920s, for example,
during the underground time
after the revolt in 1927,
'26, right, Djamaluddin Tamin
and all of the other
fellow communist exiles,
they went to Singapore and
Malaysia, but their network
is very much among the
Muslim Malay people.
It's not really with the, for example,
the communist Chinese in Malaysia.
So tracing that very specificity
of the scope of cosmopolitanism
is very important.
And then also, then this
is my second question,
what is the characteristics,
or maybe origin,
which I don't really like the word,
but characteristics of cosmopolitanism
that is specifically Southeast Asia?
In other words, what is
Southeast Asian contribution
to the history of cosmopolitanism?
- More tough questions
about cosmopolitanism.
I guess for me, if you look
at the root of the terms,
you know, cosmos and
cosmopolitanism there seems to be
a claim and an aspiration to something
that transcends the specific, to some kind
of world global universality
that one can identify
in these different cases that is of course
a form of denial, erasure,
suppression, disavowal
of specificity, of
self-interest, of parochialisms.
There is no view from nowhere, right?
And so I think in that
sense, what I find noteworthy
and perhaps appealing in these
different cosmopolitanisms
in different ways and to
different extents is the seeds,
at least the ones that
I focus on in the book
in the revolutionary context
is they each have some degree
of emancipatory and egalitarian promise.
But they also have within
them something else.
They also have within
them forms of domination,
forms of patriarchy, forms of inequality,
forms of exploitation.
They have other things there, too.
And they have the seeds
of state-making as well.
But I think historically,
if you take the template,
the template is the emergence
of these sorts of energies
and forms of mobilization that
contribute to a revolution.
And then after a revolution,
and we can see this
after the Russian Revolution,
you can see this in art
and literature and architecture
as much as you can see it
in political terms, then
there's the etatization,
the appropriation by the
state, by the nation state
in the 20th century and
the kind of evisceration
of those more ambiguous
emancipatory energies
that are then appropriated or suppressed.
And so maybe part of the project,
to go back to some of the
earlier questions also,
is to kind of, as with your
work, to kind of remind people
of other times and other places
when these kinds of hopes
and dreams inspired action
that then was appropriated by others.
And that some of those
emancipatory energies,
many of those emancipatory energies
were then absorbed and killed off.
And the origins and energies
were then disavowed.
And I don't know if that
fully answers your question.
In terms of Southeast Asian contributions
to cosmopolitanisms, I think it's clear
that Southeast Asia has really contributed
a great deal to globalization,
to communist internationalism,
to different forms of
revolutionary internationalism.
And even in the more
conventional international,
the kind of Bandung forms of solidarity.
So I think, you know, I
begin the book by saying,
when Che Guevara said in Havana in 1966,
"We'll bring you one,
two, three more Vietnams,"
everyone knew what he was talking about.
He just had to say the word Vietnam
and people knew what he meant.
So I think that Southeast
Asia is an incredibly,
just as it contributed in many ways
to the study of nationalism
and to nationalist struggles,
it also has contributed
to these sorts of forms
of internationalism and
cosmopolitanism as well.
- Thank you.
- Thank you so much, John.
We're now at the end of our time.
I'm going to stop the record right now,
and those who wish to linger
for informal chat can do so.
So I'll click the button here.